der doppelte boden knoten findet beim
anzeigen und beim stammplatz bei
verwendung
es wird eine schlaufe gebildet einmal
eingedreht und durch das entstandene
auge gesteckt
es entsteht
ich
jetzt wird die schlaufe
über den sarg gelegt
es werden jene strenge heraus
welche unten die schlaufe zusammenzieht
dadurch bildet sich das so genannte
im auge
das heil kommt durch den einzeller ring
man bildet eine schlinge
eine kleine schleife durch
jetzt wird das seil ende durch die
schlaufe gesteckt mit der langen seite
des seiles zieht man die schlaufe zurück
das elende wird durch den
eingeführt und dem seil verlauf zurück
gefehlt
am ende muss ich eine doppelte sei
außer bei der schlaufe durch welche das
ein- und auslaufen der saal geführt wird